Another movie
(audience applauds)
with two women that I've always loved might be coming back.
Lisa Kudrow is teasing us, Drew Barrymore.
"Entertainment Weekly" reports,
she recently said she'd be totally on board
for a new "Romy and Michele" part two.
(gasps) Please.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
My favorite movie ever.
Well, this comes after,
remember, she and Mira Sorvino showed up at the SAG Awards
and did like a little skit together.
The movie, believe it or not, is 25 years old.
But for my money, it is still one of the best romcoms,
comedies, films of all time.
And do you know? This is a true story.
I was dating somebody in high school
and we went to go see
(audience laughs)
"Romy and Michele's High School Reunion,"
and they didn't like it, and I broke up with them
because
(Drew and audience laughs)
if you don't like that movie,
it's not gonna work out with us.
(audience laughs)
I love when they love the two guys, or Casey Deegan,
in drama club.
Yeah.
And they're like, "Why weren't they into us?"
And they go into the yearbook,
(Ross laughs)
and they're like totally macking
on each other.
(Ross laughs)
I know.
I would die for that movie.
For that.
And if they brought it back, I mean, a streamer has to do it
or they could do like one of those miniseries,
like "And Just Like That...,"
give us a few-
Yup, yup.
But somehow, it has to come back.
Do you agree?
You guys, would you want this?
Yes, yes.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
A million percent.
My daughters and I watch that movie all the time.
All right, well, next up, (laughs)
we're gonna talk about brain clutter.
Anyone ever get that brain clutter
where you're just like, oh, when your brain is swimming
with all those tiny little to-dos
that we just can't seem to get done?
Like return, you gotta return.
You gotta repair. You gotta send a text.
Well, we have a secret weapon now.
"HuffPost" reports a writer named Serena Wolf
calls this list of small to-dos the needle list.
And here's how she recommends that you tackle it.
She sets aside 30 minutes to an hour every single Friday,
not every day, just every Friday,
to blast through the needle list.
Like doing as much as you can in just that little block.
And she says, it's a game changer.
She slides into the weekend feeling better
'cause she's crossed off her list.
One hour a week. Could you do it?
Okay.
I wanna try this.
You do? How do you do it?
I can't imagine. (laughs)
Do have lists? I'm trying to think.
I mean, I never stop.
Yeah, right?
I'm like the Energizer Bunny in bed at night,
like never, never.
(audience laughs)
I mean, I love this.
You do?
Yes I do.
Because if you're a constant doer,
or you're totally lazy, or anything in between,
I think this could work for every type of person.
'Cause we all have those weird things
that we totally escape avoidance and they just pile up,
and then they fester and eat away at us.
Like, why am I not doing that thing?
And you could just attack it right then and there,
but you don't.
So like two weeks later, you're like, God, that thing.
That thing.
This would drive me crazy.
I could never do the save it till Friday.
I would think about it Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thurs.
I would think that I was gonna have to do it on Friday.
My mom always had lists.
She had Post-its everywhere, writing everything down.
I have turned into my mother,
because every day, I have a thing next to me
where I write things.
And if I don't cross off the last thing,
I can't go to sleep, mm-hmm.
Well, you know how much we talk
about your mom here on this show.
I know, my mom.
And you are the most wonderful person.
And if you're anything like your mother,
then obviously, she's the most wonderful person.
Well, she was the most wonderful person in the world,
and she always got her list done, too.
Well, who here thinks this is an interesting concept,
the needle list?
You would do it?
(audience members clapping)
I just, again, I think it could speak
to the procrastinators
and I think it could speak to the doers
because everybody can't do everything.
And if you're really bothered
by the things you're not getting done,
to block out one hour a week, very doable.
Yeah, but wouldn't you think about it all week?
Like I would just dread Friday all week long.
(audience laughs)
No, 'cause I'm still doing a million things until Friday.
It's like for those little things.
Like I get the...
Even the word needle is like it just mm, mm, mm.
(laughs) Yeah, right?
(audience laughs)
That list.
But oh, you're gonna try it. Next week?
I saw a lot of hands raising.
I think we should try this.
And I love it on Fridays because it's true.
You go into the weekend a little lighter.
Okay, I'll try it if you try it.
I'm in. Anyone else wanna try it, too?
Yeah, all right, done.
(audience applauds)
All right.
(upbeat pop music)